معنا الان من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي نرحب بك العقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي
برغم القصف برغم العمليات البريه وما
تسميه اسرائيل بالمناورات برغم كل ما فعلت
طوال الاشهر الماضيه حوالي اربعه اشهر من
عمر هذا العدوان اعلنت فيها اهدافها بدايه
تدمير الانفاق استعاده المخطوفين
وايضا القضاء على حركه حماس اليوم قاده
ومسؤولون اسرائيليون وامريكي يتحدثون لوول
ستيت جورنال يقولون بان
80% من انفاق حماس في غزه ما تزال سليمه
ماذا نفهم من
ذلك نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره نعم لا شك بانه قضيه الانفاق
تعتبر احد المرتكزات الرئيسيه للقوات
المدافعه خصوصا وان فصائل المقاومه
استطاعت ان توظف هذه الانفاق او شبكه
الانفاق الواسعه التي تمتد على جميع منطقه
قطاع غزه بشكل ادى الى ارتفاع فاتوره
الخسائر بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني وما يجري
الان في مناطق الشمال هو خير دليل على انه
لازالت هناك امكانيه للتنقل ما بين جميع
المناطق سواء كانت في الشمال او في الوسط
او في الجنوب علما بان هذه الانفاق تستخدم
لاغراض متعدده من قبل كتائب القسام فمنها
ما يستخدم للتنقل ومنها ما يستخدم للحمايه
ومنها ما يستخدم للاسلحه ومنها ما يستخدم
للذخائر ومنها ما يستخدم للحمايه ومنها ما
يستخدم تخدم للراحه وبالتالي استطاعت
فصائل المقاومه ان توظف هذه الانفاق بشكل
ادى الى ارتفاع فاتوره الخسائر لدى القوات
التي تحولت التوغل في الشمال وفي الوسط
والان في الجنوب الان ما تغير من
استراتيجيه القوات الصهيونيه في التقدم
الى منطقه خان يونس بان الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه اطلقت على شقين الشق الاول هو
القتال فوق الارض والشق الثاني هو القتال
تحت الارض وهذا يعني بان مساله الخسائر
التي اثرت عليهم بشكل كبير جدا في الشمال
الان بداوا يحاولون تلافي هذه الاشكالات
لانها تشكل تحدي كبير جدا بالنسبه للقطعات
التي تحاول التوغل في منطقه خان يونس لذلك
نرى بانه وتيره التقدم الان هي بطيئه جدا
وهذا يعطي دلاله واضحه على انه يجري تفتيش
المناطق التي يتم التوغل فيها بشكل دقيق
جدا من قبل كتائب مختصه ثم بعد ذلك
يحاولون الانتقال الى مناطق اخرى وهذا ما
يب رر الان عمليه التوغل التي تجري في خان
يونس منذ بدء المرحله الثانيه والى يومنا
هذا لم تحقق انجاز كبير جدا على ارض
الواقع علما بان راوه المعارك في هذه
المناطق يعطي دلاله واضحه على ان الانفاق
تستخدم بشكل كبير من قبل فصائل المقاومه
وهي تؤتي اكلها في مساله ارتفاع فاتوره
الخسائر يتشبث نتنياهو وصناع القرار في
اسرائيل بانهم حققوا انتصارات من وراء
معركه غزه الى اي مدى ما جاء في جورنال
يكذب روايه النصر المحقق في غزه
الان نعم هم يحق لهم ان يقولوا ما يشاؤون
ولكن بالنسبه للخبراء والمراقبين وخاصه
العسكريين يرون ان تقسيم المستويات على
ثلاثه مستويات رئيسيه المستوى استراتيجي
وهو مستوى الاهداف العسكريه التي وضعت
لهذه الخطه ثم المستوى العملياتي وهو
الانجاز التين تحقيقه في ساحه العمليات
على مستوى القطاعات سواء في الشمال او في
الوسط او في الجنوب وعلى المستوى التكتيكي
وهي الانجازات التي تم تحقيقها خلال
الفتره الماضيه من قبل الجيش الصهيوني ولا
احد ينكر بانه استطاع ان يتوغل في منطقه
الشمال واستطاع ان يتوغل في بقيه المناطق
ولكن هذه هذا التوغل كانت له فاتوره كبيره
جدا من الخسائر بحيث ان ان التكلفه كانت
باهضه على الجيش وراينا بان هناك تدمير
اعداد كبير جدا للاليات وهناك ارتفاع
لفاتوره الخسائر البشريه علما بانه الدعم
الذي تتلقاه اسرائيل في هذه العمليه
العسكريه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن قبل الدول الغربيه هو دعم
كبير ساعد ساعد الجيش الصهيوني على
الاستمرار في هذه المعركه خصوصا وان هناك
دعم عسكري مباشر من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن قبل بريطانيا في مساله
تقديم المعلومات الاستخباراتيه لذلك
الانجازات التي حاول الحصول عليها طوال
الفتره الماضيه لا تعد على المستوى
العملياتي بانها انجاز ولا على المستوى
الاستراتيجي وانما على المستوى التكتيكي
فقط شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلحي